welcome to the bell
hey guys pete here it's a bittersweet
thing but the trailer for the sixth and
final season of the expanse is here
there are officially 291 minutes of
expanse left at least for now on amazon
spread out over six episodes and this
official trailer makes it look like it's
going to be a hectic ride as a person
that's somewhat obsessed with this book
series i can say that this looks
promising as far as wrapping up this
part of the story the visual effects
look amazing it looks like there's going
to be plenty of action and if you're
familiar with the novels you can
basically sketch out where things are
going i'm gonna break everything down
and tell you what i'm most excited about
right after this quick spoiler warning
if you're not caught up with the expanse
through season five then this video
won't be for you i will be mentioning
the book series but not giving away any
future plot points and with that out of
the way let's get into it
the trailer opens with bobby draper and
christian avasarala talking on the
surface of earth where things don't look
great and it looks like they're going to
be getting worse as the season goes on
avasarala is talking about how the
people of earth are wounded how they're
trying desperately to keep themselves
going by pretending they're not she's
talking about the aftermath of marco's
rocks hitting the earth in season five
and after a couple of shots of the crew
on the rossi holding with naomi and a
look at clarissa in the med bay with
amos we get a new shot of a different
asteroid hitting earth that's followed
by some footage of victims in an aerial
view of new york city where you can
still see how bad the flooding is on the
tynan we hear joseph who stayed with
drummer after the split with marcos
saying poor poor earther doesn't know
where she'll get her food and water
welcome to the belt we see that things
are getting worse and that some belters
will see it that way that this is earth
getting a taste of their own medicine
the inner planet governments and
corporations have restricted access to
water and air as a way to control the
population and they use that as a way to
exploit the workers and so you can
imagine that some people will look at it
that way then we go to series where we
see marco ship the pella and see him
proclaim that ceres will be the capital
city of their belter nation a place
where all belters can forever call home
if it's been a while since you watched
the early seasons remember series is
where miller was from and in season 5 it
was mentioned that anderson dawes was
the governor there the crowd of belters
on hand seemed to be pretty pumped up
listening to marco talk and we get a
couple of shots of philip including one
where he's with another belter around
his age this is a new character we've
never met then we get a shot of
avasarala floating in a shuttle on her
way back up to luna she looks happy or
at least comfortable in zero g which
might be foreshadowing her staying close
to some of the action this season which
kinda gives me mixed feelings if i'm
being honest i mean obviously it's
always nice to have her around but
you're also putting her in harm's way
she tells bobby they've located inaros's
ship and that she's got a plan in mind
then we see her coming aboard the rossi
with what i imagine is her power armor
in tow she tells the crew that the old
lady thinks that the rossi is the best
option for her operation which does
track with the early part of the sixth
book and i'm glad to see her on the ship
because that will keep her close to the
action which is a completely different
situation than avasarala initially the
crew don't appear thrilled about the
operation they don't look like they want
to get involved necessarily and amos
lightens things up at least for us when
he asks if she's getting paid extra for
this i did read the episode descriptions
and this all should be very early like
first episode early and then some of
these clips we see throughout the
trailer are related to this mission
there's a shot where we see the airlock
opening with clarissa in a suit looking
outside and then a shot of a rock that
looks like it has a drive strap to it
and we see holden checking that out
there's a sequence with holden and amos
boarding a ship and shooting the belter
inside while they're there they pull up
a display and are surprised to see that
it's tracking the course of a lot of
asteroids which it looks like the free
navy is continuing to hurl towards earth
when naomi asks what it is holden
answers the mother lode and it does look
like a ton of rocks
drummer is the biggest mystery of this
season and we got a lot of her in this
trailer we see her coming back onto her
ship the tynan and then hear her saying
that there's a war on to joseph and
michio we see that same battle scene
interior shot from the teaser with the
timing getting lit up and left with a
hull that resembles swiss cheese and we
hear a message saying captain drummer we
were golden bound now we fight with you
so it sounds like some belters are going
against the free navy and rallying to
her side of the conflict she meets with
a new character perhaps the golden bell
captain and then there's this crazy
looking raid they're involved in with a
lot of people getting shot later in the
trailer we hear kamina telling her crews
family members that she never loved them
because they were fighters i loved you
because you were builders and it looks
like they may be splitting up
temporarily on the free navy side of
things we see marco with the new
rosenfeld character that i talked about
in my last expanse video and we hear her
say a war will come soon enough later we
see her telling philip that his father
is better with him at his side and we
see them embrace hinting that there's
going to be some tension between those
two throughout the season there's a
really interesting shot of them on a
monitor which is a scene that i
recognize from the books i won't spoil
it but you can see that they're in suits
ready for battle on the pela that's
followed with naomi telling holden she
tried to save philip but she failed and
then we see him fire a torpedo after
that bobby says in the end the only
thing that matters is fighting for who's
covering your back with a couple of
shots of the crew where naomi and
clarissa share a look that seems to
signal everyone coming back together as
in there's resolution to some of that
tension that we heard about from the
comic-con panel the last bit of dialogue
is avasarala saying that she wants the
belt to see what it's doing to us i want
them to see the lies we've lost the pain
we've suffered and that's followed up at
the end with her saying we need
something to give us a reason to hope
there are a few fantastic shots in this
thing that i know exactly what's
happening from reading the books but
can't say much about them in this video
there's a sequence of shipping
containers pouring out of a hauler near
the ring gate which looks fantastic a
shot of bobby and her power armor that
looks different than the one we saw on
the teaser because she doesn't look like
she's in the slow zone here and then at
the end of the trailer there's this
little stinger of a character we haven't
met on the show that's pulled from the
novella strange dogs we see her look
around and look at one of the titular
gate builder tech animals and i couldn't
help but laugh because the way that i
pictured these things was pretty robotic
based on things from our own world and
this makes perfect sense considering all
the other stuff we've seen related to
that civilization and it will be cool to
see how they weave this into the story
of season six it's not terribly
important for what's going on inside a
soul system but it does give you a
little bit of an idea of what's going on
outside of the ring gates and at least
where things were left at the end of
season five that was kind of cut off
from the inner planets
there's a lot of stuff we don't see in
this trailer we don't see bull at all
and there's really no other character
that looks like they're taking up the
pilot role there's a ton of battle
scenes and different things going on on
the rossi nante and we only see the core
group of characters holden naomi amos
clarissa and bobby some of those people
can fly spaceships but none of them are
the same caliber of pilot that alex was
and it did seem like they were setting
up bull to take over that role in season
5. this could be a result of
availability and we'll have to see how
they handle it because none of these
characters really make sense but they
could probably make it work we also
don't see oxana at all remember in the
season 5 finale when drummer won against
the free navy in the battle with the
rossignonte part of her family left i
was thinking that there would probably
be some conflict there but like i said
we only see the people that stayed with
her in this trailer we also see quite a
bit of series including a sequence that
looks like it might be under attack and
we don't see any shots with anderson
dawes who's played by jared harris like
i mentioned earlier we did hear fred
johnson say in season 5 that he
contacted anderson dawes at series but
the creators have said that it's
difficult to get jared harris back
because he works so much so they may end
up writing him out off screen there are
a couple of new belter characters here
and it does look like there will be some
serious devastation on earth which is a
big part of the story that the show
didn't really get into last season
there's a lot of interesting details in
this thing and just to say it again the
visual effects look amazing i've talked
about the short season and how that's
disappointing in previous videos but the
one argument in favor of it was the
increased budget per episode same amount
of money with fewer episodes means you
get to spend more on each one there is
so much space battle stuff going on here
and it does look expensive and as far as
what i was hoping to see there aren't
any crucial omissions looking at this
trailer and reading the episode
descriptions i feel pretty confident
it'll be intense six episodes they're
gonna fly right by they have an average
run time of 45 minutes each with a
longer finale at 63 minutes but intense
and rushed are not the same thing and if
the season turns out half as good as the
trailer we're in for a treat and i think
that's a great place to leave things let
me know in the comments what you thought
of the trailer what you think about the
upcoming season if you want to talk book
spoilers that's great i'm always down
for that just be sure to mark them so
they don't spoil things for non-book
readers was there anything missing here
anything you wanted to see and let me
know what stood out what made you most
excited please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon